Hello. So, I'm here tonight to talk to you about critical thinking...
...and whether or not it matters.
This talk used to have a different title...
...but my friends convinced me that that was sort of harsh.
And so I needed to develop a new thesis,...
...which was not that people are stupid...
...but rather that people think badly.
But then that left me with a new problem,...
...which was why do people think badly.
Well, my first thought was maybe they don't have a lot of formal education...
...but personal experience has shown me...
...that formal education is no shield against shoddy thinking.
Next, I thought maybe they just don't have good information.
And then my final thought was maybe those people are just gullible.
I was surprised to find out that that's a word that doesn't appear in any dictionary.
Let me talk about some historical examples of bad thinking.
This is Charles Ponzi.
He was a charming Italian immigrant...
...to the United States in the 1920s.
And he had an amazing new investment idea.
Word got around about this idea and investors poured their money in.
What Ponzi would do for you is, if you parked your money with him for 30 days,...
...he would return it with up to a 50% increase, just one month later.
So again, that became a very popular idea.
Well, people at the time didn't realize that Ponzi was the inventor...
...of what's now known as a pyramid scheme,...
...also known as a Ponzi game but until they realized that...
...a lot of people made a lot of money right up until they didn't...
...when the scheme collapsed.
Ponzi went to jail for a brief time...
...and then was deported back to his native country.